how many names does Allah have 99 but
that doesn't mean he has 99 in one how
many how many Allah are there there's
one but that's that's that saying how
many names do I have9 and one I've got
two different
names 99 and Oney listen attributes are
within him so so whever they're all
attributes how many we obviously from
what we know of 99 but there could be
more there's definitely more and how
many hymns are there it doesn't say
there's there's there's many HS Allah
clearly
says only one there's only one yeah yeah
there's these 99 attributes within the
one 99 and one okay but look what's
what's your name what's your
name you have to be paying these people
them past people you have to have been
paying these guys I'm telling you they
they're on your p list they're on your
payroll I will tell you for free they
will diver from the question you're
paying you have to be this guy is paying
these guys to come on here and talk
nonsense he was paying them definitely I
will answer your question directly so
you're say what is before you do Abu yah
before you do brother yes guys this is
what I say all the time if I were to go
dude if I were to go to some random
person and tell them about the
conversations that I have with Muslims
with some of these musl not all but some
of these Muslims on here they would
think I'm making it up or or paying them
or something to say the stupid things
they say no you are definitely paying
them the last guy was even worse than
the other one before him I know he
diverted from the question about a
thousand times and he was was on repeat
it like he's a radio he was saying oh
yeah but at the time of Noah this and
this happened so I'm clearly telling you
you have to have been paying this the
I'm speaking there's no way they could
have been real people yeah they can't
they can't of they can't have been real
people I don't know who you who you've
definitely got them on your payroll they
can't have been people who are just
coming on here sincerely trying trying
to ask questions they were paid people
who came on here and they were lying out
their teeth had to they W fake people
they obviously real people people in the
comments they stupid it's clearly real
people came people just BS man just BS
literally they were repeat it's like a
radio yeah yeah I thought I was
listening for a second I thought I was
listening to a radio and repeat it the
guys want know this and he done that but
Abraham done this and he done that what
are you talking about but yeah brother
but yeah so so the question you're
you've been looking for is what is the
inil yes in fact in fact yeah so the
inil is a gospel and a gospel is
singular from what I'm referring from
what I know a gospel is singular it's
not gospels so if we're talking about
Mark Matthew Luke and John are they not
all gospels correct they are they are
one gospel just four accounts of the one
gospel but would you not say refer to
the Gospel of Luke the gospel of Mark no
it's the Gospel of Jesus according to
Luke the Gospel of Jesus according to
Mark and so on and so forth exactly
that's four books now that's four
gospels not four books four four
accounts it's four accounts of the
Gospel of Jesus so is that four in one
yes everything is four in one with these
guys three in one what's next five and
one and the guys have to be taken the P
so you guys are telling me every so if I
bring you food right now if I bring you
a pizza five P five slices of pizza
you're GNA tell me now this is one pizza
I'll say that those are pieces of the
pizza oh my dud so then but they make up
one pizza right yeah oh my
days Christian St fa to make me laugh so
so for example for example how many
names does Allah have 99 but that
doesn't mean he has 99 in one how many
how many Allah are there there's one but
that's that's not saying how many names
do I have9 and one I've got two
different
names 99 one boy attributes listen
attributes are within him so so whever
they all attributes how many uh we
obviously from what we know of 99 but
there could be more there's definitely
more and how many HS are there it
doesn't say there there there there's
many HS Allah clearly
says there's only one H there's only one
yeah there's these 99 attributes within
the one 99 and one okay but look what's
what's your name what's your name no no
no that doesn't make sense because
what's your name 991 you don't want to
ask what's your wait wait what's your
name people in the comments were calling
you wait wait Avery wait wait hold on
hold on
listen with you just told me your
gospels are four
one let's have a proper conversation
look calm down Cal down so so so listen
so in the comments people were calling
you Avery but there's some people call
you God logic right are you two HS I'm
one him with two names that's two and
one exactly just prove my point you
prove my point so two and one two two
two two
hey so we now just prove there's two
there's two of you now apparently
according to you there's two of you it's
just there see what we're showing is is
that there can be a complexity within a
singularity there can be you could be
one in one sense and more than one in
another you know what I'm saying no but
just because I've got five names doesn't
mean there's five different of me
there's clearly one of me so five saying
that you have five names names is being
the number of names is one category you
your your actual self is another
category so you have one self but you
will have let's say five names so you're
singular in one way you're also plural
in another and that you have five I'm
not I'm not plural in another because my
my family might call me one name my
friends might call me one name my work
buddies might call me one name does mean
mean people are all of those names
accurate uh that's his attributes that's
a difference you you think it's just a
name like God logic does not define
there not it's not an attribute towards
you it's not an attribute cuz you
haven't got God's Logic right or or were
you comparing yourself to God have you
got God's Logic of course I didn't know
I didn't know you was shared with God's
Logic damn man all all believers are
brother all believers rely on the logic
of God and the logic that he gives us
this is why we're undefeated this is why
everybody that comes up here listen
listen this is why everybody comes up
here looks like I paid them to say the
stupid things that they do because I'm
using God's Logic man no no no you're
not using logic I'll be honest with you
you said what is the inil the the inil
is one book that is the word of Allah
sent from Allah now can you confirm to
me Mark Matthew Luke and John is the
word of Jesus did Jesus write it down
did Jesus did Jesus everything that's in
there everything in there was it the
word of God yes so so inspired by God
wait let's let's deal with the
fundamental first okay so you first had
a problem with the the multi faceted
nature of the Gospel that we have that
Mark Mark Luke and John right these
Gospel According to you let me ask you
this
okay uh how many books are in the Torah
how many books in the Torah could you
enlighten me five five yeah go about
five books in the in the Torah
now the Torah though the word Torah is
that singular or is that plural it's
singular so just because the word is
singular doesn't mean it doesn't have a
plurality to it even though the word
Torah is singular it still has a
plurality of books that make it up so
just the same way inil singular does not
mean it doesn't have a plurality of
books that Encompass what the inil is
that doesn't make sense cuz then I can
do have everything my water bottle
singular but uh a water bottle
it might just be plural to me now now
people are going to be asking if I
people gonna be asking no it's not
because it don't make sense you're
telling me because you think the Torah
has F I'm telling you right now the
Torah personally I don't think that's
the word that's not the word of ACC
because you're bringing me a book no
look look you're bringing me a book that
I don't asking if I paid you bro they
asking if I paid you because they're
just talking nonsense but listen to this
clearly he I told you for free this
guy's not paid me he's just confir
everyone the gospel is four in one books
so so look so you said it doesn't make
sense that just because the word gospel
is singular that it doesn't mean that it
uh it it can't have like a plurality of
of books to it just like the Torah the
Torah is a singular word that has a
plurality of books that make up the
Torah why can't the inil be a singular
word that has a plurality of books that
make up what the angil is p a question
so just like how the Torah is a singular
word that has plurality of books that
make up what the Torah is why can't it
be the same for theil with theil being a
singular word that has a plurality of
books that make up what the inil is why
can't it be the same for the you there
I'll tell you why because look first and
foremost the Torah I I personally don't
believe there's five books too I don't I
personally believe that too so you
bringing me the Torah is not helping
your point it feels the Quran for
example the Quran is one book it's not
books within a book it's not bring how
ises bringing up the Torah not help it
does not help because I don't believe in
that I don't believe that's the word of
God you don't believe the Tor the word
of God if I was to explain you through
something that you don't believe and
would not make sense wait is wait your
now right now I'm talking about the
Torah right now yes oh my I need to hold
on a second just give me one second
brother one one second because this this
this is this is ridiculous so just give
me one second bear with me in the
meantime tell the people to like like
this like like the stream or something I
don't know keep them busy because I just
need to change to something keep them
busy I'm gonna address a few of their
comments now now this is where we at now
okay go on you okay you said to me that
the Torah what do you mean
by you're saying you're saying that the
Torah is not five books so then no I
didn't say that know I'm talking about
the Torah right now I'm saying that we
that is present right now alive today
with us is not the word of God so okay
regardless of if you believe it's the
word of God or not you know that the
Torah is made up of Five Books right not
the one that I know of what person I
don't know if it's made of five books
but the one we yeah what Torah do you
know of that did not contain the five
book Moses what Tor I'm telling you the
one that is mentioned in the Quran does
not mention has five books but the one
the one you're mentioning right now that
we have today has five books the one the
supposed indeed that you're saying that
you have right now is made of four
gospels which is apparently four in one
okay so I need you to tell me this since
you're saying that the Quran doesn't
specifically mention that the Torah is
made up of five books which you're
absolutely right it doesn't explicitly
mention that you know what else it
doesn't mention for example who was the
Torah given to I know I know this
argument oh doesn't specifically say
Moses was given the Torah yes but
clearly it indicates he has like brother
you don't have to be go we
know saying to you where does it say
Jesus is god well no it's not the same
make no it's not the same okay look I'm
not even asking for the exact words the
Torah was given to Moses you don't even
have to give me that give me where it
even indicates that the Torah was given
to Moses where it relates the Torah as
being given to Moses Moses look at this
Moses was given a book right with his
his brother Aon the Quran so what was he
given it's clearly the Torah if we know
from from listen from the teachings of
prophet Muhammad s wasallam and the and
all these other people the people that
came after him they know the Torah has
been given to Moses that's my proof to
you wait wait how from from from from
Prophet Muhammad himself how he got from
Allah no he got it from the Jews no he
didn't get it from the Jews so you tell
me he got the information from the Jews
so you don't make sense then so you just
prove your literally your Hadith says
that the Jews used to recite the the
Torah in Hebrew and then explain it in
Arabic in the presence of produce it
produce it OB wait if you're talking
about if he he's heard the Torah before
but he doesn't know how to read or WR
how would he be copying these things
he's hearing the stories that the Jews
are telling him about he's hearing the
Torah recited this is how he's this is
how he knows about I understand now so
what about the bit when um Joseph why
did he not copy that about the Pharaoh
I'm not saying that look I'm not saying
that he copied everything down so you're
telling
me everything telling me he took
everything that was that was right from
not listening not listening yeah go on
okay go on I'm saying
his knowledge of what the Torah was and
any tradition that came from the Torah
came from the Jews and the Christians
that's what I'm saying and so I'm not
saying that in the Quran he copied it
word for word or copied everything down
but what he did was is he took these
stories that he heard and these
Traditions that he heard and he put a
little Islamic twist to it he made this
Islamic twist to it that that's what I I
understand where you're coming from but
I'm telling you if you're correct if
you're correct according to you your
Bible says Joseph at the time at the
time of at the time the the ruler was a
pharaoh the Quran says he clearly was a
Malik he was a
king if we go to historians
now wait because you're about to build
on a false Fise it says that in the
Bible too that he was called it says
he's a pharaoh King so if I show you
that he was king of Egypt man can you
Pharaoh King don't forget the first word
Pharaoh King if I show you if I show you
in the Bible that it literally calls him
the king of Egypt separate from Pharaoh
so it doesn't say so if it doesn't say
Pharaoh what we gonna do I'mma show you
look if I show you that it it says king
of Egypt I I want you to send me I want
I need $7 so I could go get a frosty for
my girlfriend is that cool okay if it
says if it says if I show you where it
says Pharaoh King what we going to do
there it's it says both
itus so why did you not say that then so
why did you not say that I didn't deny
that you were denying say Abu you said
that the Bible doesn't refer to him as
king when the Quran does and I'm showing
you that the Bible actually does call
him King in Joseph's time well why does
it def refer to him I and Pharaoh that's
my point because Moses is writing this
and the people that he's writing to in
that time understand him to be Pharaoh
in their time there's no difference I
don't think Moses wrote that then
because Moses clearly if he's getting if
he's getting Revelation from Allah he
would clearly know that clearly it
wasn't a pharaoh there was a king he
Wass but King man come on bro we both
know the Pharaoh came after at the time
of Moses so let's not play the he was
Pharaoh they was called Pharaoh during
Moses's time D and even exactly exactly
that's my whole point that's I said
Pharaoh came at the time of Moses does
it make sense this if if Moses refers to
Joseph I'm sorry the Pharaoh in Joseph's
time as the king of Egypt and also
refers to him as Pharaoh since Cally
that's what the Pharaoh was known as in
Moses's time doesn't it make wouldn't it
make sense if he was called both in
Genesis that Moses is writing NOP
because clear that's like saying that
but that wouldn't make sense that
wouldn't make very much sense cuz if
he's getting Revelation look look the
difference between what you're saying
and you're you're saying if and maybe
but I'm telling you this is a objective
point of view did Moses get Revelation
from God so you're telling me God told
him there was a pharaoh not King so
who's I want to know which one's dumb
God or is Moses dumb one of them or
whoever my my thing is that you're
you're leaning too far on one side now
you're staying here as long as you are
because I like you but
you're why did you change the question
not hearing me you're not hearing what
I'm saying why did you I'm hearing y but
why did I just realized you changed the
question why is it where's the in no no
who on
that the reason why I changed the
question was because now you're denying
what the Torah is no I'm not denying
what the Torah is I'm denying what the
Torah is today you denied that the Torah
was the five books of Moses so now I'm
like wow you deny what the Torah I
believe what you you said it's not the
it's not the five books it doesn't have
five books no I said according to the
Quran Accord according to my teachings
not my teaching the prophet Muhammad is
teaching thisan this I mean this Torah
dides not include five books I said
today
includes no where does the Quran deny
that the Torah is made up of Five Books
it doesn't deny that that's what I'm
trying to say to you so I'm saying to
you it doesn't deny no agree doesn't not
agree so we can't right nice so now
here's my question so it doesn't affirm
nor does it deny so how do you know
excuse me how do you know that the Torah
was that the quran's talking about which
there's only one all of history is not
made up of Five Books I'm telling you
because according to my teachings this
book does not contain five books within
it within it according to what according
to what teachings listen cuz look if
we're speaking about a book if I you go
and pick up that book I'm not telling
you to bring me five books right I'm
telling you to bring me one book that's
why I realized the the Bible is a book
that contains 66 books in it exactly
that's my point now 73 to some people 79
you can have a
book you could dang how many other books
but how many other books do we go to
dude you can refer to a book like the
Bible that contains 66 books within it
or 73 for uh for my Catholic friends why
I not go to the 79 from the Eastern
Orthodox no just the not go to these
books it wouldn't make sense right how
much longer we got bro no because look
ask man I need you to give me something
don't don't be
like let's talk about the
then no how do you know that the Torah
does not have five books how do you know
the Torah doesn't have five books I'm
telling you according to my Quran that
doesn't agree nor disagree so I'm tellan
can't your Quran doesn't nice so your
Quran book your Quran doesn't tell you
whether it's five books or just one or
two or three it doesn't tell you so it
doesn't have that detail it's missing
those details so then who why do you
deny that the Torah was made up of Five
Books when your Quran listen I cannot
deny not agree so that's why I say to
you I don't know if there's five books
in there so let me ask you this now so
you don't know that's better that's
better I don't know if the Torah
that's good enough I don't know ask
you wait a second CU before we get toil
well I mean the Torah came first we got
to settle inight this but the other guys
do you know do you know of any Torah do
you know of any Torah that that did not
contain Genesis Exodus Leviticus Numbers
and Deuteronomy do I know any Torah than
that go today's today's Torah no I'll
ask it again so that you don't Mis
conscrew what I'm asking you and don't
give me an answer I'm not looking for
Al you're looking
for do you know of any Torah that did
not contain Genesis Exodus Leviticus
Numbers and Deuteronomy Allah does not
say whether the book was called Genesis
do you know of any Torah in all of
history that did not contain Genesis
Exodus Leviticus Numbers and Deuteronomy
the only book The Only book that we know
of that today is the ones we we see
today that the Jews have that's do you
know that that was not just today but
that was in the seventh century too not
just the seventh century but also the
first century not just the first century
but also before Jesus you have proof do
you have proof the Dead Sea Scrolls the
Dead Sea Scrolls is proof you have the
Dead Sea Scrolls yeah the Dead Sea
Scrolls that contain the Torah Genesis
ex and how long did he go back 200 years
before Jesus 200 years before Jesus and
when was it found uh like 1944 something
like that so it was randomly found by
who though we to know by who some people
during around the cown caves exactly so
we don't know who found it some random
people we do know who found it I just
don't know exactly do the exact same
thing we can do the exact saying Muslim
who found them actually wow no we could
do the exact same thing though with uh
with your books we can do the exact same
thing exact same thing because we let's
say for for example the Gospel of Thomas
why don't you accept that as a book
because it's late because it's late it's
a Muslim fory how long did it come how
long did it come Barnabas Thomas is but
still Thomas is still late in a Gnostic
Gospel that's why how far how long did
it come after after this I'm not exactly
I don't remember the exact dates but I
think a hundred or so years after Thomas
died actually but the same thing with
Mark though the same thing with all the
other so I gave you your answer my
friend you have you haven't because you
so the C scolls that contain the Torah
that date 200 years prior to Jesus that
had Genesis Exodus Leviticus Numbers of
Deuteronomy so do you have do you know
of any Torah that didn't contain those
five books in it I'm telling you the
only Torah we know of that today is that
them five uh um chapters that are being
uh produced or whatever you want to call
it gospels or you want to call it books
or whatever that's in the Torah that's
the only one we know of today that Torah
so you so as of now you have no grounds
to deny the nature of the Torah being
made up of Five Books right you have no
grounds to deny that right I do have
grounds what's your what what what Quran
is my ground where where did your Quran
deny it does not deny nor agree okay so
then you so then you don't have grounds
right uh if you to go back to history
then we can't I'll do my research on it
to see if there was ever even Genesis
Deuteronomy and all these other books
that you're talking
the 200 jesusa Scrolls I'll take a look
into but as for now you have no now then
as for now then know but my whole point
was the question was about in you
brought up Tor you switched it over
because you tried to go against my point
after you acknowledged that the Torah
was made up of a plurality of books and
then I related that to the Ino you then
because you saw that problem you now
denied that oh wait well no the Torah
doesn't have multiple books in it you
know I don't believe that you know
that's how we got here so now we can get
back so now we understand that the Torah
even though it's a singular word is made
up of Five Books it's made up of a
plurality of books even though it's a
singular Torah similarly the gospel is a
singular word that can be made up of a
to of a plurality of books can have four
books that make up the gospel account
yeah but you know what it is you see
with the the Torah the reason why I'm
telling you it cannot be made up of um
five different books into one is because
listen a book is singular you cannot
tell me a book now means books you
understand me and another thing reason
why I don't believe that these five
books are the word of God is because
they talk about unal living um Gentiles
and they talk about aling people and and
spreading giving information to the
Gentiles it's like wiping out the whole
of the Jew the Jewish mankind so the
Jewish people my bad so that's the
reason why I I don't believe that's
another reason why I don't believe this
this this this uh this this other books
like the tud as well foret the Torah the
tud let's see for example T I don't
believe that's the the word of God as
well so the T now it's the same
game no that's not the word you believe
in why does your Quran why does your
Quran quote from it as if it's the word
of God I'm talking about the one we have
today the one we have today obv one
today is that we have today yeah your
Quran says that we ordained for them for
the Jews yeah um if you un alive one
person it's as if you've unived all of
humanity that's in Sanhedrin I 38 that's
in the Tom where did you see me refer
that I didn't refer to that though I
when you said that that the t is not the
word of God your Quran says it's the
word of God well well obviously if it's
got bits and bits and Bobs one two words
I'm saying the full book to get one two
words even the Bible you can say same
thing for the the Bible today it says
one two bits that so wait these these
rabbis who wrote the tud and came up
with wrote it with their own hands
remember W those who write the book with
their own hands right they wrote the T
with their own hands claiming it's from
God were these guys
were these rabbis and monst prophets no
they wasn't okay did they get Revelation
no they never but obviously it's past is
orally so some people heard probably one
thing one person probably heard one
thing they probably all disagreeing with
each other so so how is it that these
nonprofits non- Messengers can get can
write down a revelation of Allah if
they're not they don't have Revelation
they don't have don't have to have to
write something down so then that would
mean if they had then that they would
have to have they would have to be
prophets or Messengers right no it
doesn't be that where where does it say
it have to be that where does it say
that prophets non Messengers can receive
no you're saying writing something down
they wrote down revelation of Allah did
they receive Revelation from Allah
that's what I'm asking difference that's
what I'm telling to tell you you say
you're talking about writing and
receiving writing and receiving
something is two different things so
where they get it from that uh to kill
to unive one person is as if you unive
Humanity where did these rabbis that was
probably that was probably the teachers
of Moses and obviously things get passed
out that's nowhere that's nowhere in the
Torah that's nowhere in the Torah
nowhere well was definitely teachings of
the Jews because if you ask them today
they they'll say that's teachings of the
teachings of the Jews that they made up
themselves where where where's that
Moses never said anything like that
Moses never said anything how do you
know we can't prove this today it's not
in the Torah well that's your Torah I'm
telling you you can't ask me how to
prove it I can't prove from the Torah I
don't have the Torah I will prove
Moses's words can you show me where
Moses ever said this and I said I didn't
say words I said teachings so it could
have been his teachings that's how they
were practice and stuff enough that's
enough now wait hold on hold on hold on
let's not run from the let's go back to
you said Muslims can't answer your
questions why are you going to the Torah
but you can't I appreciate you coming
man you tried you tried let's go back to
the question me I don't wanna I don't
wantan to like Drop you out of because
you I I liked you you're cool I'm G to
move on though okay but brother let's
talk about the in before dropped me you
said no one can't answer it maybe next
time maybe next time ah see so I'm not
the one running remember you ran you're
right you got you ran from from
answering my questions about
the dang it now everybody's accusing me
of paying you Abu everybody's saying
that I paid you now